we've got clear skies this morning we
are very very warm checking valley
temperatures look at all those 80's
still holding onto low 90's green valley
henderson the strip and downtown not
much in the way of wind now we will look
for some southeast breezes this
afternoon 80's in boulder city this
morning and upper 70s in perum our
tuesday is going to be a hot one at 110
degrees we were 111 yesterday average
high is 105. record is 114. some signs
that you're getting too much sun maybe
not hydrated enough and maybe
overheating heat cramps so heavy
sweating muscle pain or spasms got to
get some electrolytes in your system
stop exercising heat exhaustion heavy
sweating dizziness nausea headaches
maybe even vomiting you've got to cool
off get inside get into some nice air
conditioning heat stroke the sign of
that body temperatures at 103 plus
fast strong pulse maybe even passing out
you need to get call 911 get to an
emergency room anyone that has display
is displaying those two symptoms please
get them medical care right away high
pressure over the four corners but that
monsoon moisture circulating around it
is popping up showers and thunderstorms
very near southern nevada look at
arizona very active in the afternoons
and we're going to see that again today
through tomorrow and the rest of the
week we get a chance at some
thunderstorms later in the week today
hot sunny breezy by thursday a 10
percent chance of thunderstorms that's
it it could increase between now and
thursday but at least we get an
opportunity for maybe some rain
otherwise hot and sticky with a slight
chance of thunderstorms in the mountains
into the weekend